first question from michael dear michael
when will you be launching the daily
wire dating app
i'm sick of the hot singles in my area
not sharing my conservative and
traditional values
in all seriousness was that not serious
that's fair enough it seems like a
serious statement
he goes on in all seriousness i live in
the most liberal city in wisconsin
and i can't seem to meet any respectable
women it's the new spelling
this shares my values i have not left
because i have a great job and i'm close
to home and family do you have any
advice for seeking out the ladies worth
their salt or some inspiration
to up and move to a more conservative
state p.s nice name thank you michael
i reciprocate the compliment
it's tricky for me to give advice here
because i
met my wife when we were like 10 years
old or something
not saying we got married right away you
know dated other people in the meantime
but uh
but i just have a sort of different
dating experience
than many people do and i i
was never on the dating apps for
instance i
did not have to date during this
particularly crazy political time
so in many ways i dodged a bullet sorry
to gloat but that's the way it goes
i left a liberal state and moved to a
conservative state and i did it for
professional reasons first of all and
also personal reasons because it's
easier to raise a kid
in a more normal conservative state and
i love it and i miss some of my friends
in california but
basically i wish i had moved here even
sooner to tennessee i absolutely
love it a lot of people are doing this
in the country right now they are
moving to places to follow their
philosophical lights because as the
country becomes more politically
polarized you're gonna you're not gonna
wanna live in some crazy place
where everyone disagrees with you about
everything and just views the world
fundamentally differently
i'm not saying we can't have nice
conversations with people who are on the
left
i'm just saying if we're talking about
radically different views of the world
it's going to be harder to get along
there
where to meet a good woman if you're
having trouble
on the dating apps and i know people
have gotten married off the apps if
you're
not able to go to bars because of stupid
kovid
i would recommend making friends through
other affinity groups namely your church
that would be the easiest one
but even through more
interest-based groups rather than you
know religion which is the fundament
more more interests the examples of this
are
it kind of gets to my theory of how the
country is changing and and
transforming and now going back to a
different version of what it used to be
before we had standardization and mass
media sort of before world war ii
we had much more local cultures so
tennessee would be very different from
i don't know california very very
different unrecognizable maybe
now though they are still quite
different they're much more similar
than they used to be and if you go to
cities and all these different places
the cities are almost exactly the same
i've traveled
all over this country and
it's more similar than it is different
maybe that will change with polarization
again i'm not quite sure
but the the local question kind of went
away
now that the mainstream media and the
standardization is breaking
i think we are we're going away from a
common culture again we're not all
watching the same tv shows we're not all
watching the same movies we're not all
watching the same sports
we're not all watching the same newsmen
so that's breaking away in a way that's
good it's
in a sense kind of a return to localism
but it's not localism rooted in
geography it's rooted in
ideological affinity groups in many ways
so it's not that once the mainstream
media and the common culture cracks
we're all just going back to our local
vfw hall
it's that we're all going online and
talking to people who have the same
interests that we do
on the other side of the country or
maybe even on the other side of the
world
i i'm not willing to speculate now on
what that means for our politics but
what it means for you is
maybe you'll meet a lovely lady through
the daily wire uh
audience community i actually saw on
twitter there was a singles chat going
on in the daily wire community
i do think that you're going to have to
look more specifically into your
eff interest groups into your affinity
groups
than just the local bar i think the new
normal in many ways is shutting that
down
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you